So the answer is, we want to select the part
of the word that we can still use in our
solution. So we can't keep the a, and we can't
keep the lower case u, so those are positions 0
and 1. From position 2 to the end is good,
so we can produce that using the index selection. We're
going to select from s, starting from position 2. If we
wanted, we could count all the letters and select from
s to the final position. We can also just use
a closed bracket. We don't need to count the letters that's
going to select from position 2 to the end of the string.
Now, we want to get the uppercase U in front. So,
we're going to have an uppercase U added to that. And
finally, we need the print to print that out. So, here
that is in the Python interpreter. We have the definition of
s that was provided. And what we're going to do is print
out capital U plus S, two colon to the
end. And as expected, we get our result: Udacity.